hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the vondelasa
gambit which derives from the center
game accepted line which is pawnee 4
pawn e5 and then after d4 the accepted
line in the center game is pawn takes
here on
d4 and the van der lassa is bishop to c4
immediately getting material involved
into the game attacking this week in
square here on f7 typically you see
knights come out before bishops but
white says you know what if we're giving
up material we want to start the attack
as soon as possible the three things
that we are going to be looking at today
as far as variations the first one is
going to be knight to f6
attacking this pawn here on e4 the next
one we're going to be looking at is
bishop here to b4 immediately getting
their dark square bishop involved into
the game attacking our king here on e1
that's going to be most of our
discussion and then lastly we will
briefly touch on
knight to
c6 hopefully you guys enjoy this video
on the vondelasa gambit
the first version we're going to look at
is knight to f6 i think bringing the
knight to c6 or f6 is going to be the
most common just getting knight's
involvement into the game makes a lot of
sense uh knights f6 makes total sense
attacking this pawn here on a4 also
preparing to get the dark square bishop
involvement into the game castle on the
king's side any time you play a game
that you're not exactly sure from black
standpoint how to defend you usually
want to get king side safety pretty
quickly so knight f6 i think makes a lot
of sense we're going to play knight to
f3 here attacking the pawn on d4 also
allowing them to take this pawn on e4 if
they want to i think they could either
take with their knight or they could get
their dark square bishop involved into
the game one of the reasons they play
knight f6 is to get their dark square
bishop involved so they can castle on
the king side so i think those are going
to be the most common here so after they
take here we'll look at that then queen
2 d4
yes we're still down upon the material
but you can see we have a ton of
pressure on our opponent we're
definitely controlling the center of the
board and really after they've left that
pond go
they've just moved their knight two
times and now they have to either try to
move it back a third time or they have
to try to defend it but they don't have
a lot of good ways to defend it pawn to
d5 really just loses to bishop takes on
d5 because then after knight to f6
then we could just play knight to c3
just getting more pieces developed into
the game we can get our bishop involved
if they want maybe knight takes knight
takes here
and then dark square bishop castle on
the queen side even if we want to castle
on the king side so we have tons of
options here and we're not even down
a pawn in material anymore so i think
that's going to be a pretty tough way
for black to defense i don't think d5 is
going to be all that popular but you
definitely could see it
f5 gets pretty tricky
in that we have already announced that
we want to play a pretty aggressive game
and start to attack our opponent and now
they're just weakening their king side
and usually when this happens i try to
get more material involved into the game
so knight to c3 makes a ton of sense to
me maybe they played knight to c6 trying
to get some of theirs involved into the
game attacking our queen but you can see
we could just play queen to
d5 now this threatens the move queen
take or queen 2 f7 checkmate they pretty
much have to play something like knight
to f6 but then we can just start to
gobble up material they played knight
takes we played knight takes here on e4
they play pawn takes and then queen to
e4 take and gaining tempo here attacking
the king here on
uh e8
and you can see
things just start looking that great we
can play bishop here to g5 getting that
involved into the game then castle on
the queen side we have much more
aggressive lines that black would have
to deal with so i don't think playing d5
or f5 are going to be
preferred by black
they could play
knight to c5
this does get the knight out of harm's
way because it is protected by the
bishop i do think this blocks where this
bishop can really go they're going to
have to play pretty passive just to play
bishop here to e7 if they want to castle
on the king side so this does block off
a lot of the ideas that they want to
play but from here we're just going to
stay aggressive bishop here to g5
attacking the queen here maybe bishop d7
as we talked about but then as soon as
they play bishop to e7 we can
automatically take this pawn here on g7
this not only attacks the rook here on
h8 it also defends this bishop here on
g5 notice we have the queen and the
knight both defending this bishop here
on g5 so it's going to be pretty fine
now they play rook 2 f8 then we castle
on the king side and we have a pretty
good setup and you can see they no
longer have king protection it's going
to be really difficult for them to
castle on the queen time the queen side
any time soon so i think the best move
really from black is to just played
knight to f6 but you can see they've now
moved their knight three times and it's
really just come back to the original
position we're gonna play knight to c3
just getting more material involved into
the game maybe bishop here to e7
same thing as before get our dark square
bishop involved into the game castle on
the king side castle on the queen side
and that is a race to attack our
opponent remember
there's different variations in here and
we're down upon the material so we have
to stay aggressive and there's no more
there's no better way to stay aggressive
than to castle on opposite sides
typically if you castle on the queen
side they castle on the king's side it
is just a race to throw everything in
the kitchen sink at your opponent's
king and try to overwhelm them and since
we have so much more material developed
we control the center of the board that
should not be a problem at all
now if we come back to this position
instead of the knight taking here on e4
i also think that it's reasonable that
you could see bishop here to b4 prepares
to castle on the king side which makes
sense checks our king here on e1 we're
always going to be playing pawn to c3
stopping that i think they're always
going to be playing pawn takes here on
c3 that's everything i've ever seen you
could see some weird stuff and that's
okay as well
and from here there's kind of two
options
one option is to take with our pawn here
on c3 attacking the bishop the other one
is to play castle on the king side
and
one reason i like castling on the king
side is this very similar to the danish
gambit where they could just keep taking
pawns
but then after we take here yes we're
down two ponds of material but you can
see we have a very aggressive setup both
of our bishops are developed they're
attacking the king side of the board we
have the only
pawn in the center of the board we've
already castled so we have king safety
our queen is open so it can get anywhere
it wants to if it wants to get pretty
aggressive here come here to b3 putting
pressure on the f7 square attacking the
bishop
so many different options things are
wide open black just hasn't really
developed too many of their pieces and
does not have king safety yet
so that i think is completely fine but
the reason i actually like taking here
on c3 all comes down to
what do they do after we say
pawn takes on c3
because i think most of them are gonna
play something like bishop to c5 this
gets it out of harm's way they recognize
that no pawn can really push up and
make this bishop move we can't play a
knight and make it move so this keeps it
central it attacks this pawn here on
f2
the problem though
is white now has the move pawn to e5 and
this i think is the main reason that you
would want to play pawn takes here on c3
forcing the bishop to move now that
doesn't have to move we'll look at one
of the variation where they could play
just d5 instead attacking our own bishop
here but after we play pawn to e5 i
think they're usually just going to play
knight 2 g4
and now we can get pretty aggressive we
can play bishop takes here on f7
attacking the king king takes here and
then knight to g5
check and you can see we have a pretty
aggressive setup here
we can get our bishop involved to the
game our queen obviously is gonna get
involved into the game at some point
this opens up to go ahead and take the
knight right here so lots of different
options that white has here and so i
think this is the reason that you
actually want to take here on
c3 now i think the best option for black
i think it's very difficult for them to
find is after we take here on c3
is to play the move d5 attacking our own
bishop in the center of the board in
this case we're going to go ahead and
take their bishop
and then they may play bishop comes back
here to
a5 the problem is for black this is also
a mistake they really need to be
bringing their bishop back here so they
can protect their king
and this is another reason that this is
such a dangerous trap for black to fall
into
is because yes they played the correct
move i think with pawn to d5
but after we take here they can still
make more mistakes because after bishop
to a5 we play the sneaky move bishop to
a3 and it may look like wow this is
nothing i don't understand there's no
threat here what are they doing well one
it stops black from castling so that's a
big thing but the other thing is white's
next move is going to be queen to e2
with the threat
of eventually coming here to e7
because this would be czech and so
there's no real way to stop this you
know they could play bishop here to e6
but then we just take it with our pawn
they could play queen to e7 but then we
just take that with our queen here and
it's protected by the bishop
and that's why this move here on a5
bishop to a5 is so bad although it
doesn't really look that bad because it
looks like yeah we still have the bishop
involvement to the game it's pinning
down this pawn to the king and so you
want to maintain that pressure but it's
actually a huge mistake because you want
to use this dark square bishop for black
to be able to defend the queen coming
here to e2 so how could black really
respond here lots of ways they could try
but maybe pawn to
c5 okay we just take with our bishop but
that does open up for the queen to come
here to c7
queen to e2 this is the critical move
we've talked about here king 2 d8
potentially now we just start pushing up
with our pawn pawn to d6 attacking the
queen queen to d7 now we get our knight
involved into the game maybe they swing
their rook over that's fine we can
castle to get king safety here uh knight
to g4 attacking tonight we're just going
to go ahead and take here but this
knight here on g4 also opens up for the
rook to come down take here but then
after the exchange we take with our
knight here on b8 we're also still
threatening this rook here on e2 with
our bishop so they're probably gonna
have to move their rook bishop here to
d4
and you can see their bishops really
aren't doing anything their bishop here
on a5 which was pinning down our pawn
it's just hanging out here light square
bishop's not doing anything their king
is completely exposed and we have a
pretty good setup here after the rook
takes we play pawn h3 forcing this
knight back here the knight was
protecting the rook and so we're just
attacking so much material they are
going to lose a significant piece of
material and their king is still exposed
so that is why
if we come back you know so many moves
yes i think d5 makes a ton of sense but
after we take here they still have to
worry about playing the wrong move
bishop to a5 they really need to come
back something like bishop to
e7
all right now if we come back to the
beginning we looked at knight to f6 and
all the ways that you could potentially
counter attack that
next one we're going to look at is
bishop here 2 b4 just immediately say
hey if you get your bishop bomb to the
game we're going to get ours involved
into the game but we're going to go
ahead and check you same thing as before
we're going to play pawn to
c3
after they take we're still going to
take here we don't even have the option
to castle on the king side so there's
that
keep in mind as we looked at before
bishop 2 a5 was a mistake it's still
going to be a mistake but it's going to
be a mistake for different reasons
before we were playing you know our our
pawn was in a different spot here and so
we're going to be looking to play queen
to e2 because our pawn was going to be
on at d5 but the threat now is queen to
d5 this threatens the move queen takes
here on f7
checkmate and so they usually have to
play something like queen to e7 but then
we can just take their bishop here on a5
so that would be a
massive mistake from them so we already
recognize they can't play bishop to a5
and so where else do they go maybe
bishop to
d6
okay that does block off just their
d-pawn moving forward a little bit
now we just played knight to f3 getting
more material involved into the game
knight to c6 here castle on the king
side
and from here i think play continues
completely fine from both sides we still
have the threat here on f7 and it is
going to take them a couple moves before
they can even castle on the king side we
already have king safety here
and we have a lot of different ways to
get our bishop involved into the game
our queen has lots of avenues as well
they don't have as many and their light
square bishop is blocked off the other
option is to get their queen involved
into the game okay so we play pawn to c3
queen to f6 here
and this is an interesting threat
because if we take their bishop
then all of a sudden they can just take
our rook here on a1 i still think
that that is the preferred way to go it
is pretty risky for sure but after we
take their bishop they take our rook
here we're going to play queen 2b3 with
the threat of bishop takes here on f7
i think they pretty much always are
going to play queen to f6 if not that is
going to be a mistake they really need
to get their queen back here to f6 to
defend this but now we can play knight
to f3
yes they did take that material but
they're just moving one piece around the
board we're getting more and more
material involved into the action we can
castle on the king side here and so yes
we do need to stay aggressive in this
spot because we just traded off a rook
for a bishop we still have the bishop
here here
but this is a situation where if you
look at this and you say absolutely i
want to play this all day long because
this is very aggressive then this is a
variation that you may want to go down
in the vonderlasta gambit there's just
so many different ways that you can
attack your opponent
the last thing we are going to touch
briefly on
is instead of the bishop coming here to
b4 you could also see knight two c6 and
then we played knight to f3 the reason
we're not going to talk about this too
much is because this right here is
the scotch gambit and i have a specific
video going over the scotch gambit
everything that you'll see in this
specific variation i will have a link
right at the end of this video if you
want to watch that i'll also have a link
in the description if you want to watch
that but just know this variation is the
scotch gambit i've already covered it so
definitely check that out if you like
this game and you're like i want to make
sure that you're covered with knight to
c6 because it is very popular
make sure you check that out but thank
you guys so much for watching
the video if you haven't already hit the
like button let me know what you thought
of the content today if you have any
other recommendations i would appreciate
always looking for new content ideas
thank you guys i'll see you in the next
video
you